caught on camera two people stealing
hundreds of dollars in clothing by
kicking through the front door this
happened last Wednesday at Hottie World
on Maryland Parkway right near Flamingo
8 news now reporter Ryan Matthey shows
us why attorneys believe the thieves
might not face much repercussion
[Music]
pricey merchandise and a forced exit
losing money for you know running the
business management at this hottie World
store did not want to be identified in
fear of retaliation from these two
escaping with nearly eight hundred
dollars worth of clothes last Wednesday
he says they locked the front door as
the store began to close and when they
couldn't escape around it they went
through it nothing we can do because I
you know we're not actually allowed to
contact the you know customer just in
case of for our safety and management
says that doesn't even cover the cost of
nearly two thousand dollars to replace
the door frame and the glass in such a
short notice that the problem retails
across the valley are facing but one
that attorneys say carries a slap on the
wrist it's a first offense you're not
going to jail the criminal attorney Macy
M polski says while Petty larceny's
could carry up to six months in jail
that's not how many end up as the courts
frequently plead down there's a lot
nastier crimes out there where people
deserve prison do you really want to put
someone one in prison who's stolen 2500
dollars
you know it's just not going to happen
Betty larceny school at most is what
he's witnessed to get out of it this
once it gets dismissed you can see on
the record which is a civil procedure
and then when that's done if anyone
looks they won't see that you're charged
with a crime
[Music]
today Metro says the thieves haven't
been identified the attorney adds the
amount of products stolen actually
determines how much jail time is
possible in this case and since store
property was also damaged he says they
could face another misdemeanor but he
doesn't expect it